meet long long the elephant eight months
old and 300 kilograms and still hungry
he was found with his leg trapped and
taken to a rescue center in sichuan bana
southwest china
neither
for a long time biodiversity took a back
seat to economic development in china
now the country is putting much more
effort and resources into protecting its
wildlife
the population has grown so much in fact
that they've been setting out in search
of pastures new
this summer a herd of wild elephants
packed their trunks and went off on an
adventure
they traveled hundreds of miles and
spent 17 months on the road
their long march broke the chinese
internet and was the story of the summer
some experts said the reason the
elephants left is because of human
development
as humans continue to expand elephants
need new habitats
they've introduced new systems to
monitor wild elephants and minimize the
chance of conflict
this is how the technology works out in
the field
so this trail is effectively an elephant
highway but it's half elephant made they
use it often but it's half man-made too
it's been widened to encourage them to
come down here so that they can go past
some of the monitoring equipment devices
like that that can send an alert to the
rangers they know the elephants are
coming it means they can shut off the
highway down there and allow the
elephants to cross the road safely
this is what can happen when they do
come through
a farm completely leveled the trees
knocked over for the food inside
we wanted to try and find some elephants
in the world
this is outside the sanctuary we visited
earlier and is their true natural
habitat it's rough going
the elephants remained elusive they're
wild animals after all
but this year the rangers set up what
they call an elephant canteen a site
full of their favorite foods and one
well away from humans for both species
of safety
all of that is good news for long long
when he grows up and returns to the
world
right now though safe in the sanctuary
his priorities seem to be head-butting
correspondence
am i being attacked
and like most people over christmas
eating lots of food tom cheshire sky
news sichuan banner south west china